[Música]
vamos a ver cómo se comportaron los
mercados el día de hoy y para eso está
Jorge Hurtado acá en el estudio de
directo América y la noticia del día
pues tiene que ver con esa decisión de
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos que
sube nuevamente los tipos de interés se
trata a Santiago de un aumento de 75
puntos básicos por cuarta vez ya en
cinco meses que sucede esto Ahora el
precio del dinero en la mayor Economía
del Mundo queda en el rango de entre el
3,75% y el 4% y no se descarta tampoco
Que las próximas subidas para luchar
contra la inflación sean un poco Menores
en el comunicado los responsables de la
política monetaria afirman que los
efectos sobre la demanda en los sectores
de la economía más sensible a los tipos
de interés como la vivienda por ejemplo
ya Es evidente pero que se necesita aún
más tiempo para que baje la inflación la
reserva Federal esperaba que los tipos
tocasen techo en torno al 4,5 el próximo
año pero ahora se cree que pueden llegar
incluso al 5% la idea Al subir los tipos
de interés es encarecer los créditos Y
hacer que el consumo baje siguiendo la
lógica que a menor demanda los precios
también bajarán el peligro es ahora que
la desaceleración sea tan grande que
provoque incluso una recesión económica
escuchamos sí que decía el presidente de
la reserva Federal
uniseidas permítanme decir esto es muy
prematuro pensar en una pausa Así que la
gente cuando escuchan retrasos Piensan
en una pausa es muy prematuro En mi
opinión pensaba hablar de una pausa en
nuestra subida de tipos tenemos un
camino por recorrer en nuestra política
necesitamos continuas subidas de tipos
para llegar a ese nivel suficientemente
restrictivo Y por supuesto No sabemos
exactamente dónde está
Jorge cómo reaccionaron los mercados a
raíz de esta decisión bueno Wall Street
cerró con pérdidas y uno de sus
principales indicadores del nasdaq cayó
un 3,36% tras la nueva subida de los
tipos de interés en Estados Unidos el
índice de las tecnológicas se vio
afectado por la mala jornada de empresas
como Amazon Netflix meta y tesla entre
otras en Europa las acciones que habían
arrancado en verde cerraron a la baja
atrás de la subida de los tipos de
interés en Estados Unidos y en la región
en América Latina hubo cierre mixto
exceptuando el merval de Argentina que
cerró en negativo y pues justamente a
raíz de estas decisiones pues Fue un mal
día para las grandes empresas en Estados
Unidos así es bueno CVS Walgreens y
Walmart acordaron pagar alrededor de
13.800 millones de dólares para resolver
miles de demandas estatales y locales
esto por las acusaciones en contra de
sus farmacias de manejar malos
medicamentos opioides para el dolor CVS
por ejemplo dijo que acordó pagar unos 5
mil millones de dólares en 10 años
Walgreens acordó unos
5.700 millones de dólares en 15 años
Mientras que el gigante Walmart prometió
pagar 3.100 millones de dólares La
mayoría por adelantado con más de 3.300
demandas a partir del año 2017 los
gobiernos estatales locales y otros
tribales de los nativos americanos
acusaron a los fabricantes de
medicamentos de minimizar los riesgos de
sus analgéticos
y a los distribuidores y a las farmacias
de ignorar las señales de alarma que
indicaban que las recetas se terminaban
en un tráfico ilegal dejamos Estados
Unidos de lado hablemos ahora de América
Latina y la reacción que hay en
Venezuela después de la visita del
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro y
la reapertura de las fronteras que esa
visita significó un paso más en ese
restablecimiento de las relaciones y es
que ahora lo fabricantes venezolanos
tienen un nuevo reto económico en el
camino las importaciones colombianas un
ejemplo de ello es Michel teaning un
fabricante de zapatos que ha
sobrellevado varias crisis económicas en
Venezuela y ahora va en el panorama la
llegada de productos colombianos durante
años el sector manufacturero de
Venezuela lidió con controles de Divisas
y precios que de cierta forma
obstaculizaron la producción así como la
hiperinflación y la falta de
financiamiento por cada 10 productos que
lleguen a Venezuela desde Colombia su
país exporta apenas uno escucha que
decía sobre esta reapertura de fronteras
y está reactivación económica entre
ambos países
con la frontera ya lo sabemos todo ya
sabemos todo lo que
lo que tenemos lo que no tenemos Si
parte una competencia que tenemos de
nuevo en el país full time
tuvimos momento difícil con Brasil con
china co India y todavía estaba aquí
pensamos que también por Colombia
seguimos en esta pelea Muchas gracias
Jorge por este reporte de las noticias
de economía a continuación en directo
América el debate
[Música]